welcome back to the second part of this
webinar which introduces machine
learning from an applied perspective
targeting specifically researchers and
practitioners
of applied econometrics who think about
how to add machine learning to the
econometric toolbox
and one to understand how novel tools
based on machine learning
can improve practical empirical analysis
in the previous module of this webinar i
argued that
machine learning is particularly good at
solving
prediction problems where we want to
find a good
prediction function from some training
data that extrapolates well to new data
points
i also argued that the solution to such
prediction problems
has been essential to the progress that
has been made
on solving machine intelligence problems
in this module i want to ask how machine
learning does so well
at predicting especially in very complex
data
and using very complex functional forms
i will then go on in the next part of
this
webinar to discuss some implications
of the way that machine learning works
and i will particularly be interested
in asking the question how machine
learning applies
when we're actually interested in
estimation including and causal
estimation
for now however i will fully focus on
solving a prediction problem so here is
our setup
i assume that we have a training data
set
with data points that constitute of an
outcome y
and and right hand side variable or
covariate x
and our goal will be to predict y from x
to make more precise what that means
let's assume there is also some loss
function
that loss function expresses the cost i
have to pay
whenever i predict y hat
when the truth is y and i deviate
from the truth y
our goal is then to predict the outcome
y
on a new data point drawn from the same
distribution
based on the covariate x and using some
prediction function f
hat in a way that this average loss is
as small as possible
now the way that i have said that so far
sounds very much like standard
econometrics there's some outcome y some
covariate x
a first difference between standard
econometrics and machine learning
is simply that these variables are
usually called differently
whether you talk to an econometrician or
somebody who is trained in computer
science
and specifically what i would call an
outcome variable y
would be called a label in machine
learning and what i would call a
covariate x
is typically called a feature so let me
rephrase
the goal of machine learning the goal of
machine learning
is to take some training data set
with label data so we have
labels and features for every instance
in our training data set
and from that we want to find a
prediction function
such that the average loss or the risk
is small when we predict the label from
the features on new data points
and i should clarify that here i am
talking about
supervised learning supervised learning
meaning that we actually have labels in
our training data set
and we don't have to for example find
structure in the x covariates without
being guided by those labels
two standard version of this prediction
problem come to mind
the first chord regression is
when the outcome variable itself is
continuous
a standard loss function that we often
use
either for convenience or because it has
good
properties for the specific task at hand
is square error loss
where our goal is to minimize the
average
squared difference between our
prediction and
the true label on new instances drawn
from the same distribution
in other words the loss function here is
simply y hat which is our prediction
minus y which is the truth squared
so two examples that i will use
throughout
today's module we could for example be
interested in predicting log house
prices
why of a new home based on the
characteristics
x of that house in some survey data of
homes
with the same distribution and so in
that
case we would use whatever we know about
our training homes in order to find a
relationship
between house prices and characteristics
so that we can then
say something about houses whose price
we don't know
whose price we want to determine but
where we have
those characteristics or features
available a second example i will use
throughout the module today is that of
predicting consumption
based on household characteristics and
that turns out to be a very important
task
for example when you think of property
targeting and the targeting
of social programs to those people who
are particularly poor
where consumption may be a good measure
of their property
a second canonical case of prediction is
when the outcome of
interest itself is binary
and in that case we call the prediction
exercise classification
let's think of the case where the
prediction itself is binary
so basically the truth is 0 1 and i give
you my best guess of whether that
variable is 0
1. in that case there are two ways in
which i could make
an error and therefore two cases in
which we may want to
associate a price with the error we make
the first case would be the case that
the truth is actually zero
but the prediction is one we would call
that a false positive or a type one
error
a second case happens when the truth is
one
but my prediction is zero we would call
that
a false negative or a type 2 error
now if i now wanted to design a loss
function i could for example put certain
prices
on type 1 on and on type 2 error
possibly
informed by the specific problem i care
about and then
try to find a classification function
that minimizes
that error or that minimizes that price
associated with those errors
in many cases however when we are in the
case of
binary classification we actually
predict the probability
of the outcome being one and in that
case
one popular way of quantifying
the quality of the classification rule
is to plot the receiver operating
characteristic curve
that on the x-axis has the false
positive rate
and on the y-axis it has a true positive
rate so where every false positive rate
which is the proportion of false
positives
at as a fraction of all
negatives meaning the fraction of false
positives
as a fraction of false positives and
true negatives taken together
i then plot the true positive rate which
would similarly be
the fraction of true positives among all
positives that are in the sample so in
other words
the fraction of those that i call one
among all that are actually one
so i can now do that at different
thresholds
so saying that i call everybody a one
whose probability
was predicted probability is very high
and i vary that threshold i can then
plot
the false positive rate and a true
positive rate against each other
and the further i am to the top left of
that graph
the better my prediction is therefore
another way of quantifying the quality
of binary predictions of classification
is often to look at that curve and ask
how far to the top left is that curve
which i can for example do by
integrating the area under it
which gives me the area under the curve
so while i will not go into much detail
here
about doing classification meaning about
doing prediction with a binary outcome
i think it is helpful to have heard the
terms receiver operating characteristic
an area under the curve or auc in order
to
understand that these refer to different
ways of quantifying the quality
of an classification function in other
words
quantifying the quality of a prediction
when the outcome of interest
is zero or one
i now want to go back to the goal of
prediction in the case of regression
meaning our outcome is actually
continuous
so let's assume that we want to find the
prediction function
f hat such that the average
squared error or the mean squared error
relative to the true outcome y
is as small as possible
for example we could try to achieve that
by using linear functions
these linear functions very much like
linear regression which is what this is
and would simply put a coefficient on
the different covariates x
where i assume that those covariates or
features are themselves continuous
variables
so from the training data for example i
could pick
the coefficient beta in my linear
regression that provides the best
in-sample fit
and this is something we are very used
to this is simply linear regression so
what does linear regression do
it says my goal is to minimize the
outside
out of sample mean squared error what is
the best thing i can do well i simply
look at the data i have
and i ask which set of coefficients
minimizes the error
within the data i have and that is the
coefficient
that i want to choose so let's step back
for a moment and let's ask ourselves
how good is this method which you are
very familiar with because it is simple
simply linear regression how good is
this method
at solving the prediction problem at
hand
so first of all there is some good news
which is we know that linear least
squares
or linear regression has a number of
optimality properties
and that apply to this case for example
we know
by gauss markov that if all the error
terms
here are homoscedastic meaning the error
doesn't systematically
vary with the covariates x
then ols is indeed the unbiased
estimator
of the coefficient beta that has the
lowest variance
now i just said a whole bunch of things
i said that
it is up that first of all i noted that
it is unbiased
because i said it is the optimal
unbiased estimator and second i said
that among all unbiased estimators
it has low variance but it is not
immediately clear whether this is
exactly what we want when we talk about
out of sample prediction
and indeed we can now ask the question
whether these properties
translate into an optimal predictor out
of sample as well
i now want to go through a somewhat
formal argument to understand
whether the linear regression estimator
is not just good at
estimating the parameter beta in a sense
that we just discussed which means
it has zero bias and it has low variance
but whether this prop these properties
also translate into a good prediction
solution
and to do so i look at a new data point
i
assume that that new data point is
actually generated by a linear
relationship
between the covariates x and the outcome
y and by some additional noise
so i assume that this new data point is
given by y equals
beta times x plus some noise epsilon
when i now estimate my coefficient beta
by some beta hat so by the or lesser
or less solution in my training state
data set then i make a certain mistake
the mistake corresponds to the
difference between my prediction y hat
and the truth y or in other words my
prediction beta hat times x
minus the truth beta times x minus
epsilon
when i now square this up and i take the
average over it
averaging both over the jaw of the
training sample
and over the error term epsilon
then we see that this
error has multiple components first of
all
i always make some error because there
is this
additional term epsilon that i cannot
get rid of
so there will be some irreducible
variance that will appear
in my loss calculation
secondly there is going to be a
difference
between the true coefficient beta
and my estimate beta hat
so we have the difference between the
true coefficient beta hat
and beta up here and we have the
difference between
the true coefficient beta and the
estimate beta hat down here
but this part of
my loss actually i can write as a
combination of two parts
first i can ask on average if i redraw
many training data samples
is my beta close to my beta hat close to
beta
that is the bias part which is the
difference between
beta and the average of beta hat
and second i can ask as i redraw my
training sample
how much does my beta hat vary from draw
to draw
which contributes variance so in other
words
the loss that i obtained has three
components
it has one component which is
irreducible noise
it has a second component which is the
bias
meaning on average how much is my
coefficient away
from the true coefficient and it is a
third part which is variance
which means as i calculate the
coefficient again and again
how much does this coefficient vary from
draw to draw
now this type of decomposition called a
bias variance decomposition
is an important framing of the challenge
of good prediction
within econometrics and statistics
because it shows that
when my interest is good prediction
meaning i want to be close to the truth
on average
then an estimator that is unbiased
is not necessarily an optimal estimator
because
while it has zero bias so while this
bias component here
is zero it may mean that the variance
component
is higher than it has to be and i
can sometimes do better by balancing
those two against each other
in other words by resolving the bias
variance trade-off
optimally now for machine learning
functional forms can look more complex
than this linear regression and
sometimes the loss functions are also
different than the square error loss
so i personally prefer a forming that
says we have a trade-off here between
approximation on the one hand and
overfit on the other
so what does this mean approximation
bias happens
whenever my function is not able
to approximate the function well even on
average
even as we resample the
[Music]
function many times while it is able to
approximate well
if it is very flexible and therefore can
fit
the function that i want to fit in great
detail
on the other hand such high
approximation quality also means that
there is high overfit which means that
from draw to draw
i always fit not only the
signal not only the true relationship
between y and x
but also a lot of the noise also a lot
of what is epsilon here
leading to a high variance so in general
i therefore like to call this
and trade-off between approximation
overfit which generalizes nicely
to other machine learning methods that
are not necessarily
um in the same space as the simple
linear regression
to explore this approximation overfit
more and to give an example that doesn't
rely on
the math that i just showed let's think
of a case
where our goal is to fit this
relationship here between variables
between covariates x and outcomes y
where my goal is to find a function then
that's predicts well on new data points
so here i
looked at those in this case eight data
points and i used a simple linear
regression between
the outcome y and the covariates x in
order to find the relationship
and now i could try to find out how what
it does by
seeing how well this line fits when i
draw new data points which are here in
red
so i call the blue data points my
training sample
i call the red trader training the red
data points my training sample
and my test sample and my goal is to
use the blue data points to use the
training sample to be as close as
possible
to the test sample points with respect
to my regression line
so in other words i would love to be on
a line that is as close as possible to
those red points here so that i predict
their vibra y value well as a function
of their x value
now let's think whether we can do better
than what we see here
for example what we could be doing is we
could use a more complex function that
is not just
a simple linear relationship between y
and x but we could for example instead
have used
a polynomial of degree 2 or parabola to
fit the same
so this parabola so this blue line
that now is curved actually fits
the points in the training data set
better
because it is more flexible is it able
to capture the relationship
of those blue points within the training
data set better
however at the same time we see that the
fit in the test on the test data points
actually get work gets worse
so what happens here we have a more
complex function
this more complex function is able to
approximate the relationship
between the um
x variables and between the y variables
and the x variables
in more detail however at the same time
is also overfits more
because some of the flexibility is used
not just to fit the true relationship
between y and x better but also to fit
some of the noise
and this one becomes even more extreme
as we add more degrees to other
polynomials so for example
as i add two more degrees here and i
look at a polynomial of degree four
i see that the blue line starts to fit
the
points on in the training data set
almost perfectly
however it fits the points on the test
data set
in a worse and worse way so what's going
on here
well as we add more degrees of freedom
to our functions meaning as we make
our functions more and more flexible
which here i expressed by adding
additional
polynomials to my regression and
as i add these degrees of freedom my
in-sample fit which is blue here
gets better and better so the in-sample
fit goes down and down and down
because the more degrees of freedom i
add
the better can this function approximate
whatever the underlying
relationship is and the better it will
actually fit the data
it has already seen at the same time
for the fit on new data points which is
what i'm after here
recall that my whole goal is to find a
function that does well in predicting
out of sample
and for those new data points the
prediction quality will increase
meaning the loss will get lower and
lower and lower but at the same time it
will also start
to fit more and more to the
idiosyncrasies of what is going on
and therefore the loss at some point the
net loss will
will increase and the prediction quality
will decrease
because the negative effects of
overfitting outweigh the positive
effects of better approximation
so to summarize as a model becomes more
complex
it starts to fit the true function
better and better
so its approximation quality increases
but at the same time it also starts to
fit the noise better and better
and the overfit also increases and hence
when we do machine learning when we want
to be able to predict well in very high
dimensions
it is important that we don't just use
flexible functional forms that are able
to
express that relationship well but that
we also limit the expressive
expressiveness or in other words that we
use regularization
in order to control how much overfit we
allow
and optimally in this example and that i
just showed
would we then find a point where those
two tradeoff in a way where the overall
prediction quality
m is better
i now want to give a few concrete
examples how such regularization can
look like
the example i just showed we simply
varied the
polynomial degree in our linear
regression in practice that may not be
the wisest way
of constructing more complex or less
complex functions
especially not in a case where there are
already a lot of x covariates available
so instead what we will do here is we
will explicitly include regularization
meaning we will explicitly limit the
expressiveness
of the function still staying for now
within the framework of linear
regression
specifically rather than running the
ols solution where we minimize the
in-sample fit
we minimize the in-sample fit subject to
some constraint
that says that our function is not all
too complex
and specifically we will implement this
by saying
that we use some norm or some pseudonorm
on our coefficients and we say that
those coefficients are not allowed to be
too large so what are the typical norms
that we consider
here the first one is actually not a
real norm but it is very intuitive it
says
let's limit the number of coefficients
that are allowed to be non-zero
so in other words when i use this first
criterion here
what i would do is i would say let's
find the regression fit
that only uses a specific number of
variables
say c of the available variables
and all other variables have to be zero
and based on those variables i try to
find the best fit
so this would give me a spa solution
however it has a big downside that it is
computationally infeasible to run
because i would practically have to try
out many different combinations of
variables
in order to find the optimal fit instead
one frequent way in which we recognize
is by using a norm that says
let's put a limit on the
absolute value of all the coefficients
in the sense that we take the absolute
value of the coefficients in our linear
regression
and we sum over those absolute values
and then
don't allow this absolute sum of
coefficients
to be too high a third
very well-behaved way of regularizing
would be to instead
use the euclidean norm or the sum of
squares of those regression coefficients
and to say let's find a solution where
the sum of squares of those regression
coefficients is not too high
in all of those cases would we
practically achieve
that we have a lever according to which
we can control the complexity of our
function
for example by saying that only a given
number of coefficients can be non-zero
or that the total size of the
coefficient isn't allowed
to be above a certain threshold
i will now go through two of those
examples specifically those
corresponding
to the one norm and those corresponding
to the two norm
so meaning those corresponding to the
sum of absolute coefficient sizes
and the sum of squared coefficient and
and throughout i will um for as a
technical assumption
and for practic practicability assume
that these coefficients are not
penalized on the intercept so we don't
here want to
kind of shrink the intercept and and
that we have already normalized
also i'm already normalized the x
covariates so that the different
directions are actually comparable
and make sense to put a norm
on on those coefficients the first
example i want to consider
is the example where we limit
the size of the coefficient in terms
of the one norm or the sum of
individual absolute coefficient sizes
so what would that mean so let's take a
very simple case
where our coefficient is just
two-dimensional
so beta has just two directions going to
the right
and going to the top here let's also in
this case
consider the unconstrained optimum
and now rather than allowing this
unconstrained optimum
let's say that we put a limit of one on
the one size of this coefficient
what does it mean that the one ohm of
the coefficient is limited to one
it means that all of the coefficients
that i'm allowed to use
have to lie within this
simple diamond around the origin
and therefore rather than finding the
unconstrained optimum
which is in the center of those
concentric
circles i would instead find the point
that is closest to
that center according to
the distance that is implied by
prediction here
and within the feasible set meaning
within
that smaller set of coefficients that is
feasible
in this case now in practice we would
actually not solve this problem
we would in many cases solve the
lagrange relaxation of that problem
which replaces the constraint of the
coefficient
not being too high by a shadow cost that
says
you basically have to pay a price
whenever that coefficient
increases meaning that we put a price on
the size of those
coefficients themselves and instead we
solve the
lagrangian rule that says we want to
minimize
the loss that we have in sample plus a
cost
for the size of the coefficient
so this specific regression is called
lasso regression
and i now want to go through a few of
its properties
the first property that you can already
see on
this right graph here is that it tends
to produce
outcomes that are not just shrunk
meaning the coefficients are smaller
than those for or less because we
associate a cost with larger
coefficients
but they often are also sparse meaning
this regression method also selects a
subset of variables
that are used in the prediction
and makes many of the variables exactly
zero
and the reason for that is that the
feasible set
for this constraint that we have
discussed before
is actually while it is convex
it is also it also has kings meaning
that
in some cases it will produce solutions
that have exact zeros
so one way of understanding what the
lasso does is that the lasso is
capitalist
when the lasso could choose multiple
coefficients that are non-zero
and these coefficients contribute to a
sim
in a similar way to the prediction it
tends to just
choose one of them so it tends to choose
winners so it
tends to be capitalist and as a
consequence
it tends to produce solutions with many
zeros
so how does this look like in practice
in practice
we can vary the cost lambda that is
associated with more complex
coefficients in our last regression so
here is one graph in which i did exactly
that
so i ran a lasso regression and i varied
the coefficient lambda
so in this case the lambda is very high
on the left the lambda is very low
on the right so the axis here is
inverted from the usual
that means that on the left there is a
very very high cost
of having a coefficient that is non-zero
and indeed we see if that cost is high
enough the optimal solution will
actually set all coefficients to zero
now each of those colored lines is one
of the coefficients
so as we decrease our lambda as we make
it cheaper and cheaper
to include coefficients we see that
some of the coefficients start to be
non-zero and also start to
increase as we reduce the cost of larger
coefficients
interestingly more and more of those
will enter our support so more and more
of those coefficients will be chosen
but it doesn't necessarily mean that all
of those coefficients
will increase it can also be that they
first increase and then decrease again
as other coefficients are included
so this again is one way of doing
regularization it's one way of
controlling the complexity
of our linear regression solution by
saying
let's use a constraint that works very
similarly to saying
i only want to fit a linear regression
on a limited set of variables
but instead of limiting the number of
variables which would be computationally
very hard and would have some
undesirable properties
i instead of that
want to find a solution where the size
of the coefficient isn't too high
where in this specific case i measure
the size of those coefficients
by the sum of the absolute values
another popular and very similar
regression method
is rich regression where instead of the
sum of absolute values
i choose the sum of squares of the
coefficients
in my in my penalty parameter
so now i have to pay a price whenever
the sum of squares
of the coefficient gets larger so
how would that look like in our previous
picture so in our previous picture
where we considered um how the
constraint set looks like
that limits this parameter this penalty
or the size of the of the coefficients
to a specific number
and that means that in this case we
would limit them
to coefficients that all lie within a
circle
around the origin so specifically if for
example
i limit my parameters to be
in within a maximum of
one with respect to the sum of squares
then i would exactly limit the
parameters i can use
to a concentric circle around the origin
with a radius of one
and i would pick the solution that is
closest to the oles solution
in a specific norm implied by a
prediction
within that within that circle uh
closest to the or less solution
according to that distance metric now
unlike the lasso the properties of
ritual regression
are quite different while rich
regression still
leads to lower lower
size of coefficients because it puts a
price on higher coefficients
it is actually unlikely that rich
regression set some coefficients exactly
to zero
instead if there are multiple
coefficients that can play a similar
role
meaning they have a similar role with
respect to the prediction they produce
which tends to be socialist meaning that
in doubt it will give
the it will distribute the predictive
power between multiple coefficients
and produce multiple coefficients that
are non-zero but not as high
rather than producing a few that are
non-zero and high and a lot that are
zero
so in other words this socialist
estimator
does not produce sparse solution instead
it tends to produce solutions
where all the coefficients are not too
high but not
none are too close to zero one
interpretation of this estimator is
that it can be interpreted as a bayesian
posterior
where i'm assuming that i have priors on
my coefficients that are normal and
centered around zero
so it expresses a belief that
coefficients are more likely to be
closer to zero
than further away which leads to exactly
that kind of shrinkage
we have now seen two ways in which we
could
restrict the complexity of linear
regression the first way the lasso
tended to be capitalist and set certain
coefficients exactly to zero
the second or ridge tended to be
socialist
and distribute the coefficients in a way
that they weren't
too high coefficients but it also did
not put any
exactly to zero there is a third method
called the elastic net which mixes
between those two by adding a penalty
that mixes between the rich penalty and
the lasso penalty
and in that case i could both play with
the degree
to which i want to put a price on
complexity so
the parameter lambda as well as a
parameter that is usually called alpha
which tells me and how i mix those two
against each other
now these were two estimators that we
often call machine learning estimators
but honestly they are quite close to
linear regression
they also coming out of statistics the
rich estimator is a very classical
statistical estimator
however i use this as an entry point
into our discussion of machine learning
because
despite these estimators being quite
close to linear regression
they have many of the general structure
that a machine learning estimator
typically has and specifically
many supervised learning algorithms
meaning many algorithms that
are constructed to solve a prediction
problem
are characterized by a combination of
features first of all by which function
class
they optimize over second by the way in
which they regularize
meaning the way that they control
complexity and
third by the way that they solve the
optimization problem
of finding an estimator that
optimizes fit subject to the
regularization constraint
the linear regression estimators that i
showed are only some examples
and i now want to show some other
algorithms that fall under the same kind
of structure
to motivate the next kind of estimators
that i want to look at
i want to consider one important example
of using
prediction methods in public policy and
that is poverty targeting
in poverty targeting our goal is to find
those households that are in
particularly
in particular need for support
and so we can effectively think of this
as a prediction problem
where the outcome of interest is
consumption
and the variables we have available so
the features we have have available
is whatever features we have for example
administrative data
that we can use to target and so
effectively we are now solving a
prediction problem
with household characteristics on the
right hand side
and consumption or in this case we use
log consumption on the left hand side
let me now give you a very concrete
example
where we simply predict log consumption
using just two variables the two
variables
we consider here is the number of
residents
on the x-axis and the number of rooms on
the y-axis
and here we see the predictions
by color gradient plotted as colors
so specifically we see here predictions
based on the linear regression
of log consumption on a constant
rooms and residence and we see
that a linear regression by the nature
of how it is constructed has these very
global gradients
that translate to a gradient running
in this case from the top left where
consumption
is considered to be particularly high to
the bottom right
where consumption is considered to be
particularly low
note however that not everywhere on this
graph
will there actually be households in our
sample so let's instead look just at
those households in the sample
and just for those households in a
sample we see that they're actually very
few households that have both
a very high number of residents and a
very high number of rooms
but there are some that have a low
number of residents and a high number of
rooms
and there are some that have a low
number
of rooms and a high number of residents
so let's see how this linear regression
that tries to
fit a global relationship between those
two
variables and log consumption
compares to the actual values in our
sample
in terms of what actual consumption is
so while on the left i plot predicted
consumption
on the right what we're looking at is
actual consumption
and we see that this roughly
lines up in the sense that yes in the
top left
consumption is indeed very high which
are those people
with a small number of residents in a
large number
of rooms and on the right where the
number of residents is very high
it looks like consumption is indeed very
small however
when i look at this i would argue that
the linear relationship
on the left is not really very good at
expressing the relationship
of those two variables and how they
affect
the outcome which here is log
consumption
so specifically when i look at this
i would say that there could be some
interaction where
the question how the number of rooms
affects consumption very much depends on
the number of residents
so specifically there's a clear gradient
on the left here
so for a low number of residents the
number of rooms
seems to go up as consumption goes up or
i should be more precise
consumption goes up as the number of
rooms goes up
however that relationship is less clear
on the right
it seems to be that basically most
people
who live in a household with a very high
number of residents
have low consumption or are likely to
live in poverty
so in other words there seems to be a
relationship here that is a combination
of
some kind of binning where there may be
a critical threshold
in terms of the number of residents and
some interaction
where the relationship between
the consumption and number of rooms also
depends
on the number of residents not just in a
simple additive way that linear
regression models
so one way we could now go about that
is we could step back and say well
didn't look like this
specific function worked very well so
why don't we try out a few other linear
regressions
where for example we by hand create some
of those features
we could for example by hand create some
of those bins
and we could then include interactions
in our linear regression
however that sounds very tedious and it
is unclear whether we would be able to
do this iterative process
well when there would be many more than
just those two
variables instead what i now propose to
use
is a method that automatically searches
for those kind of interactions and
specifically
i now want to introduce regression trees
a regression tree tries to fit a
different functional
form than the linear regression type
estimators that we discussed so far
specifically the regression tree
predicts the outcome by recursively
splitting across different features
creating a decision tree where each
split
corresponds to asking whether one
feature is below or a certain or above a
certain threshold
and then forming predictions in the
final leaves by
averaging over all the instances that
fall within that leaf
so let's look at one concrete example in
this case
let's assume we want to predict house
prices
and and in this case this regression
tree that see
we see in front of us means that if
the number of bathrooms is below 1.5 in
other words if the number of bathrooms
is zero or one
then the average house price is 9.4
which here is in log units
or if the number of bathrooms at least
two meaning we are going to the right
here
and then the average house price is
around
10 in logs so
that would give me one prediction
function but of course i may want to be
able to
get to a more precise prediction so i
could add
more layers to our prediction function
and now create a whole decision tree
that maps
the different features to the
predictions in the leaves
so in this case this decision tree would
not just take
continuous variables into account but
also some discrete variables
so it would be able to split in the
following way
if i have an instance meaning in this
case a house
where the number of bathrooms is below
1.5
meaning the number of bathrooms are 0 1
and
the floors of type 4 5 or six
then the predicted house price would be
9.1 in logs if however for example i had
a house with
seven bathrooms which means i would go
right on the top
and then i would also go right on the
bottom
and sorry then i would go um right on
the bottom as well that's correct
and so my predicted house price would be
11. and so in principle i could expand
these regression trees more and more and
i could add more and more layers
so let's see how such a method would do
in our poverty prediction example from
before
on the left here i'm plotting our o less
fitted values
and we saw that by the nature of ols or
less tries to fit
one global gradient meaning that the
marginal contribution
of the number of residents and of the
number of rooms
is unaffected by the value of the other
of those variables the regression tree
goes in the opposite extreme
the regression tree recursively fits a
tree
that tries to explain the outcome as
well as possible
by recursively splitting and thereby
finding interactive effects so for
example this tree here
first splits by number of residents and
then within
number of residents if the number of
residents is very low
starts to split by the number of rooms
while if the number of residents is
higher
may split again by the number of
residents
and thereby it is able to express
a strong interaction effect between
those two
specifically that the gradient with
respect to number of rooms looks quite
different
for low number of residents than it does
for a high number of residents
and indeed it looks like that in this
data a high number of residents by
itself
is already indicative of low consumption
while only among people among households
with lower number of residents
we see a clear gradient with respect to
the number of rooms
i now want to discuss how to find
an optimal tree specifically there are
two
challenges with finding a great tree
here the first challenge is actually
computational
it's not easy to find a tree that fits
optimally
and that problem we typically solve by
using
a greedy optimization algorithm which
recursively finds a tree which is
something i
mentioned repeatedly in passing so that
just says that rather than finding one
optimal tree
we find a tree by always doing the best
thing
one step ahead but not necessarily the
best thing overall
so in other words we fit the tree by
first splitting across the variable that
looks best in the first split
and then within each of the leaves
splitting again by the variable that
looks best within that leaf
and then fitting again and at the third
level within the variables that look
um best within the respective leaves
without
taking into account that i will further
split the
the leaves but simply doing it one step
ahead
so that's the first challenge the second
challenge
is that where do i stop right i could
simply continue
splitting more and more i could always
improve my fit
by adding another split by for example
in this case
on the bottom leftmost leaf splitting
further
than just by those two variables or
three variables that are splitted at
that point
so in other words why wouldn't we simply
continue to split more and more and more
until there is only a single home
left within each of the leaves well
the answer is pretty intuitive if there
was really only a single home
left within each leaf we would be able
to fit whatever data we've already seen
perfectly but at the same time it's very
unlikely that this would produce a good
prediction out of sample
because for a house that we have not yet
seen
the leaf it will end up in there will
only be one other house that may
actually be quite different
and that may turn out to be a very bad
prediction so in other words we again
see that there is an approximation
overfit
trade-off here so in this case
for example the number of levels that we
allow our tree to have
so the number of levels at which it can
split
determines the approximation but also
the overfit
the more levels we have the better the
approximation is
the better this tree is potentially able
to fit
to any even very complex relationship
but at the same time the more overfit we
get so the more idiosyncratic
this fit may be which could then
actually make
our outer sample prediction worse so
as before we have the following
structure we have a function class
the function class here is the function
class of regression trees
we have a regularizer which could for
example be
the number of levels of our tree it
could also be something like
the minimal number of instances i want
to have within each of my leaf
before i stop splitting and then finally
we need an algorithm that actually
solves that problem for us
which in this case i briefly mentioned
is a greedy algorithm meaning
an approximation algorithm that gives us
a good result even if that result is not
necessarily an optimal one
so this means that this tree falls very
much
in the same follows very much the same
structure that ridge regression
and lasso regression did although the
function class is quite different
and the regularizer used of course is
also specific to that function class
however just like in the case of
lasso regression or ridge regression for
the tree i have told you
that we should regularize meaning we
should choose a complexity parameter in
order to avoid
that the complexity is too high but i
have not actually told you
how to choose a localization parameter i
how to choose that lambda that expresses
the price of complexity
for ridge and lasso or i have not told
you
how to choose the number of levels that
our tree should have
so before i tell you how this is done in
machine learning
i want you to think about that for a
moment how would you go about
choosing the right parameter
well here is a trick that we can use
assume that we
split our data into two parts
and as we did in the pictures before
we fit our data on some data points and
then we use some other data points in
order to see how well we do
before i fitted our data on eight data
points and i looked at eight other data
points
in order to see how well we do now we
repeat this
for all the different complexities we
consider so in the
stylized example before we considered
first a simple
regression line that was linear we then
considered a parabola
meaning a polynomial of degree two and
then we also considered a polynomial of
degree four
and rather than taking as our guide to
choosing how complex to be the in sample
fit
which is what happened within the blue
points only
which would only tell us that more
complexity is good
we could now simply use the fit on those
red
points and say how well do we do on data
that we have not yet seen
of course that's a great thing to do if
you have a lot of data
meaning that we can still use a lot of
data to fit our function and then a lot
of data
to see how well we do that would then
allow us to choose our regularization
parameter optimally
in practice however data is often scarce
so let's take the case where we actually
don't have the luxury of having those
eight points and then an extra
eight points so we don't have the
blueprints and the red points in
addition
but let's assume we only have those blue
points so we only have those
points that we have already used
to fit our data on so what could we have
done differently
in order to get information about which
organization parameter to choose
and the answer to this is that we can
use a trick
by repeating the holdout exercise that
we ran here
which was that we held out some data
that we hadn't looked at for prediction
exercise and repeat the same
in sample within the points that we have
already
seen so specifically what we could have
done is we could have done the following
among our eight points that we used
before to fit our
regression line we hold out two of them
at a time so the first time we do it
these two red points that you see in
the top left quadrant here those two
we do not include in fitting our
regression line
and instead we use them to evaluate the
fit out of sample
when we do it a second time we take hold
out to other of the points
third time three other points the fourth
time
to other of the points so in other words
we divide our
set of points in this case into four
groups every time we hold out one of the
groups
we only use all the other groups and
then we evaluate how well we do
by seeing how well we do on average
across this
holdout exercise so this is called cross
validation
and when we think about how to choose
the regularization parameter
we could either do that by doing a
holdout sample
meaning we create an out of sample in
our sample
by simply not using certain points to be
fitted
but in order to avoid losing a lot of
sample size
we could then extend the same to
cross-validation which means that we
create repeated holdouts
within our sample so this is how this
would look like
we create false before these faults were
four false
every time we use only the
data that is not in the current group
for fitting our function so this would
be the red data in every case
and we hold out the data that is in the
currently active fault for validation so
here we hold out the first fold
we would then calculate our error
meaning the loss that we incur
when we predict from the red to the
green
points and we would then evaluate our
full fit by averaging that
error over all those folds
meaning we produce an arrow that on
average
gives us the answer how well our
function does
out of sample
the secret source of machine learning
therefore does
include at least one additional
ingredient
in addition to using very flexible
functional forms
and limiting the expressiveness using
regularization one key element is also
to use the data to learn how much to
actually regularize
which is called tuning and typically we
do that
by doing cross validation which is the
method that i just briefly introduced
so here therefore is the typical
structure of a machine learning
prediction exercise
that also translates to many
applications that
you will hear about in future webinars
so we typically divide the sample into
two parts
one on which we fit our function in a
second that we hold out for final
validation
on the fitting sample our goal is to
obtain a prediction
function f-hat which we do by first
running cross-validation
in order to find which parameters we
want to
use for the complexity of our function
so in other words
we use tuning data data-driven tuning
using cross-validation
to determine our regularization
parameters
we then fit that function and then we
use that function and we
estimate its final properties for
example its loss
on the holdout sample so why is it
important that we hold out
some additional data here well despite
our best efforts and using
cross-validation
in our fitting sample because we have
now chosen all of our tuning parameters
based on the data itself the laws that
we obtain in cross validation may still
be optimistic
because it was evaluated at the best
possible choice of tuning parameters
in terms of the measurement of our
loss to cross-validation so when we do
such work it's always important
that we keep some final data that we
have not touched to verify how well we
are actually doing
and here is where the firewall principle
comes into play
as long as we make sure that
we have not used the additional holdout
sample
other than for final validation of the
final function we have not
used it at all for choosing the function
as long as that is given
then very simple econometric guarantees
and make sure that
our final loss estimate for example is
unbiased and can be estimated well
with valid standard errors while
whatever we do
on the fitting sample um does not have
to follow
any specific protocol but can include
um trying out some different methods
since that would not affect our final
estimate
and so that gives econometrics in my
eyes
two different roles on the two different
sides of that firewall
first of all for sure we want to be able
to have
a guarantee on how well our prediction
function does
in the end and we achieve that by taking
a holdout sample
and by using for example valid standard
errors
creating confidence interval for the
performance of our function
on the total sample at the same time in
a fitting sample
econometrics can be extremely helpful in
understanding better
what kind of function is likely to do
well in a certain case
however in the end which function does
better is a purely empirical question
it is a question of which function
does well out of sample and we can show
to have good auto sample properties
assuming that our only goal is indeed
the prediction exercise of finding one
that predicts
well out of sample so that liberates us
somewhat
in what we can do on that fitting sample
we can use different functional forms we
can see which one of those
look best and we can even combine
multiple of those
which is something i will go back to in
a moment
so far i argued that two of the
machine learning methods that we
encountered specifically
regularized linear regression and
regression trees
have a common structure in that they
combine
very flexible functional forms with a
regularizer
so with a way of limiting expressiveness
as well as a way of using the data to
decide
how much flexibility to allow
of course there are a number of
important researcher choices here
first we have to actually know which
loss function we want to optimize for
and that may depend on our specific
application
second we have to make sure that we
split and manage the data in a way
that the final estimate actually
represents
a estimate of a loss that we care about
in a way that we for example make sure
that we predict an outcome of interest
in a way that is representative of the
way that we
in the end want to use our prediction
function
another important choice is how we
represent the features in our data
especially for linear regression results
may look quite different
depending on how we represent the
information in our x variables
and finally importantly we have to
decide in the first place
which function class and which regular
riser to use
so far as i said i focused on linear
regressions
with regular rises given by limits on
their coefficients as well as trees
where as regularizers for example i
discussed
the number of levels that the tree has
or the number of
of instances that should be at least in
each
of the leaves i now want to
i now want to argue that this structure
is more general
and encompasses many other machine
learning prediction methods as well
so specifically we can characterize many
of the methods that are available
by a combination of function class
and regularizer in many cases there's
also an additional level
of which optimization algorithm to use
let me give you one extreme example
for neural networks which we discussed
in our first module there are different
ways
of regularizing them so first of all
note that
a neural network was basically something
like
a logit of a logic of a logic so it was
a function
that depended itself on functions
of the input or a function
of a function of a function of a
function of the inputs
so these neural nets can become
arbitrarily complex
the more layers we add so this already
suggests one first
way of regularizing which is limiting
the number of those layers
the less layers the less expressive my
neural network is
in the same way the more
connections there are between layers the
more expressive my neural network is and
therefore also the more prone to
overfitting it may be
now that may be a pretty obvious way of
regularizing but there are some ways
that are less obvious
here's one particularly smart way so one
smart way of regularizing is called
early stopping
it says rather than optimizing the
neural network
more and more and more why don't we just
stop the optimization algorithm
at a certain level for example after a
certain number of stops
that will mean that the optimum i find
is not actually an optimum within my
sample
but instead stops short of trying to fit
the in sample fit optimally
now that may sound like giving up on
optimization correctly but it actually
has the feature of regularization
it has a feature that avoids excessive
overfit by not
regular by not optimizing too much with
the additional feature
of not needing that many
optimization steps and therefore running
quicker
in addition to those different machine
learning predictors
we can also combine machine learning
predictors
from different function classes with
each other
in that case we could for example use a
weighted average between those different
predictions
where we choose the weights themselves
in the same way that we would choose
some regularization parameter
for example by cross-validation in order
to find a combination that does
particularly well
in terms of prediction now it may not be
that surprising that
on average these ensembles do pretty
well because
they basically invest in a portfolio of
different prediction algorithms
what may be more surprising is that such
ensembles basically
outperform each individual predictor
including the very best ones
routinely at prediction competitions
meaning that a combination
of multiple prediction algorithms from
different function classes
seem to do consistently better than even
the best individual predictor suggesting
that there is some complementarity
between the different function classes
a second way in which we can combine
models
is by combining models of the same class
some of the most successful
out-of-the-box machine learning
algorithms that work particularly well
on the kind of
social science data that we often deal
with
are actually ways in which we combine
multiple trees
into a more complex predictor
the first way we could do that is called
bagging or bootstrap aggregating
and in the case of regression trees
aggregating many of them together will
be called a random forest
so rather than running a simple
regression tree where we just took a
take a take a single tree we instead
repeatedly draw bootstrap samples from
the data
we then construct trees from each of
those
bootstrap samples and when we form
predictions we simply average the
predictions
across those different trees
so while before we obtained predictions
that were either from linear regression
or a single tree i now want to show you
how it looks like when we form
predictions from
a regression from a random forest
in the case of poverty prediction
or con prediction of consumption in this
case from number of residents
a number of rooms so as you can see by
combining many trees the resulting
picture is actually quite smooth
there is some weird areas here where
it looks like with a high number of
rooms
and a high nub of residence suddenly the
predicted log consumption goes up again
and it's non-monotonic my best guess is
that that's simply because there's not
enough data in that area
but when i look at the big picture here
it is able to both
capture the interactive effect of
residents and rooms as well as the
gradient
of rooms on the left in a much more
smooth fashion
that the individual tree was so just to
compare those three with each other
ols has very smooth coefficients but a
very global structure that does not
really allow for interactions
unless i explicitly model them that tree
allows for interactions but at the same
time as a very crude way
of splitting up things that is not very
smooth the forest here
does considerably better by actually
combining some of the smoothness of ols
with the ability to also fit into
actions
just like the tree
a second way in which trees are often
combined and improved
is by boosting boosting means i first
fit a simple tree
then i look at the arrows i make and to
the error i make
i fit a second simple tree i construct a
new error
relative to my prediction target and
then i predict the arrow with the 30 and
so on
and that's why i combined many trees
with each other
so rather than going into more formalism
how this works let me just
show you a picture so this here would be
the first few steps of a booster tree
algorithm
where we assume that the truth which are
the
um which are um which these blue points
are drawn from
basically uh are taking
one of five different values and are
locally
constant so what happens with the first
tree so this is simply using a simple
tree stump meaning a tree that just
splits once
the first tree simply selects two areas
to the left and to the right
of that third bucket here meaning that
the first three buckets on the left
the second two are on the right
um and then it forms residuals meaning
mistakes it makes relative to the blue
points
and then it fits a new tree to those
residuals
in this case it looks like this new tree
splits the
four buckets on the left relative to the
right to the bucket on the right
and then those trees get added up to one
combined prediction
we form residuals again we fit a tree to
residuals the new tree gets updated and
so on
so what i'm showing here you you hear is
the first three iterations
as well as iterations 18 19 and 20. so
there's quite a lot going on in between
but we see that by iteration 18 the tree
has actually already perfectly fitted
what's going on here
and from then on it just starts to round
off the edges a little bit more
so in that case we would likely learn
that would be good to stop
this boosting algorithm after not too
many steps
which here would be an important tuning
parameter meaning we can regularize
by simply saying don't do it too often
stop after a given number of steps
and also in each of your updates don't
update too much
in addition to those machine learning
algorithms that i have now mentioned
i also wanted to mention one whole
paradigm that can help us
construct good machine learning
algorithms which is
doing bayesian regularization so when
you think
about what a bayesian method would do a
bayesian method is characterized by the
idea
that i combine the data that i see
with a prior i have over how the
relationship of
variables could look like so
specifically in the case of rich
regularization
for example we could interpret rich as
saying i have a prior
that my coefficients are normally
distributed and not too large
and i then form my posterior after
looking at the data
in order to form good predictions so
therefore bayesian methods naturally
provide some sense of regularization
because they are shrinked towards the
prior they don't let the data
overwhelm they don't let the noise
overwhelm
um the signal because they
shrink the information that i see
towards the prior thereby balancing
approximation and overfit against each
other
so in general these bayesian methods are
powerful way of constructing regularized
predictions
and some of the most successful one
including which regression
but also bayesian trees
are actually performing incredibly well
so let me just recap what the main
ingredients
of a successful machine learning
algorithm that i showed you
today are first of all using flexible
functional forms
that are able to capture the
relationship between y variable and x
variable well
second limit their expressiveness or in
other words use a regular riser
to make sure that there is not too much
overfitting
and third learn how much you should
regularize
from the data itself as i mentioned
there are important researcher choices
left that you have to consider
when you use such a machine learning
algorithm when it comes to choosing
function class and regularizer
we saw that you can actually also choose
multiple ones and then
do some more tuning in order to decide
how much weight to put on each
i now want to end here with two comments
the first comment is on implementation i
don't have time
to go into detail in this module on how
you would implement these methods
but i wanted to point out that all of
the machine learning methods
i mentioned today are readily available
in all major programming languages where
i would say that
r python and julia are the three
most natural programming languages to
work in
when you consider using machine learning
r in particularly has become a language
that has many of those language
those those methods available while also
being very
amenable to doing applied econometrics
so in many ways it would be the language
that right now
i would recommend if you are interested
in applying machine learning
in kind of an applied econometrics
context where maybe computation
and how long it runs is not your main
concern and and you want to combine
some conventional statistical statistic
analysis like linear regression analysis
with machine learning or you may want to
use some modern
methods like those developed by my
colleague susan athey
which are all available as our packages
a second comment i want to make here
is a comment on where all these methods
come from
a lot of what i talked about is actually
not new it has been known in statistics
and has been used in statistics for a
long time
for example the idea that i can improve
prediction by shrinkage
goes back to at least james and stein
who showed that
for high dimension linear regression
here high dimensional means there is
is at least three covariates we can do
better
by including some data driven shrinkage
in order to improve
our prediction quality random forests
themselves
predate many of the recent search in
machine learning
were introduced by brahman in 2001.
machine learning is by some seen
as just a fancy word for non-and
semi-parametric econometrics
and indeed many of the prediction
methods
that we use today are quite similar to
some of the methods that have been
discussed in statistics in econometrics
however i would argue that something new
has happened here
one is simply that we now have much more
data available
in an automated way that we can all
download and work with
including for example satellite images
that are now
all digitally available and available in
a way that our computers can actually
work with them
we have the computational power meaning
we have both the hardware to compute but
we also have the software to
perform that computation we also have
functional forms that work on some of
the data for example finding good
functional forms finding good neural
nets that perform
good image recognition is by itself a
big achievement
and and the focus on prediction that
machine learning
brings with it unlike some estimation
tasks in econometrics
focuses the goal
and the way that we achieve things more
on
an engineering competition that is
simply about finding good predictors now
we will discuss
next module whether that's the right
thing to go for or not
but at least if i want to focus on a
prediction problem
then there's focus on prediction and
allows us to basically turn
finding good predictor into an
engineering competition
and finally i would say there are some
new theoretical interesting insights
that are coming out of research around
machine learning
that have increased our understanding um
of prediction very high dimensions to
name just a few i think the double
descent phantom
phenomenon which i'm not focusing on
here which
amends our understanding of the biased
variance tradeoff is one example
as well as some better theoretical
understanding of deep learning
and tree-based methods
okay so let me recap machine learning in
a way that i presented it here
often is a combination of using very
flexible functional forms
regularization and tuning but now that
we have understood that the question
for me is what do these features
of fitting a function actually imply
about the properties
of the fitted prediction function and
how can we therefore
use the prediction function we get out
of it in applied work
and the background is that that we
hardly ever focus a pure
face a pure prediction problem because
often the question that we are
interested in
are more causal in nature or we want to
have some guarantees
on the object we get out of it so
therefore
after first motivating
what we're doing right now by pointing
out that machine learning is very good
at prediction
and that prediction solutions are behind
many innovations
in machine intelligence and by today
talking about
how many of those machine learning
methods work i will
in the final and next module talk about
how we can use the output for machine
learning and how that output relates
to classical estimation output for
example from linear regression
see you then